martiniquaise martinique
les informations épidémiologiques qui
nous sont régulièrement communiqué
indique que nous sommes confrontés à une
crise sanitaire sans précédent
nous devons faire front
comme à chaque fois que la martinique
faire face à une épreuve collective
chacun de nous à leur devoir de se
protéger mais aussi le protéger les
autres en appliquant des gestes simples
et en respectant les consignes de
limitation des déplacements et des
comptes à ceux qui ont voyagé et ont pu
avoir été en contact avec le corona deus
ont l'obligation de se faire connaître
et de se faire suivre par les services
de santé en appelant le 15
pendant ce temps encore indéterminé
l'activité économique et social de notre
pays sera fortement ralentie voire take
to b il n'est pas au ton de rester
solidaires
par mesure de précaution j'ai pris la
décision le fermer nos services au
public
cependant pour nos aînés et les
personnes fragilisées
j'ai organisé un service particulier les
personnels soignants et aidants sont en
premier lieu ils ont mon soutien et mais
j'encourage mans nous devons être tous
responsables en ces temps troublés
être responsable c'est ne pas céder aux
surenchères et aux rumeurs qui propagent
des germes de division
j'ai souligné au représentant de l'état
l'urgente nécessité
d'une gestion de la crise partenariale
incluant compétences expertise
responsabilités que la collectivité ou
dual martinique martiniquaise martinique
un mot d'abord agi avec dignité
gallo le court sans foi et agissons un
peuple conscient mais si on pile un
siège